it's really a pleasure to welcome to the
program today Douglas rushkoff who's a
media theorist professor at Kuni Queens
College and also host of the team human
podcast as well as author of the new
book team human from WW Norton a really
great to have you on Douglas big admirer
of your work oh thanks it's good to be
with you so maybe to start with you to
get our audience into sort of your
framing and sort of point of view on a
lot of this stuff you've said that
technology and markets often are crafted
or end up inherently having an
anti-human agenda which is interesting
sort of language to use what is that
agenda and how does it develop well I
mean really that agenda developed I mean
as far as I can tell really in the late
Middle Ages with the invention of the
charter of monopolies which is kind of
the proto corporation and central
currency that both of those were were
invented really to prevent the rise of
the middle class and to preserve the
lays feet you know we had the beginnings
of what looked very much like internet
culture in the late Middle Ages when
people came back from the Crusades and
they opened up these trade routes they
had little local markets with local
currencies that were optimized for
transaction they were getting wealthy
and that was a problem for the
aristocracy that hadn't worked in you
know ten centuries so they came up with
a monopoly currency which was basically
like almost like some kind of a Windows
operating system that you use it or you
can't transact at all and it was this
growth based interest based currency
that if you borrowed some in order to
transact you had a pay back more you
know in order in order for the economy
to keep going and instead of being able
to have your own business you had a work
for one of the Kings chartered
monopolies as an employee
selling your time rather than the value
you created so the innovations the as I
I'm currently anti-human and that they
disconnected workers from the value they
were creating we got brands to
disconnect
from the producers who from whom they
were buying stuff and we got mass
marketing and mass media to really
disconnect consumers from one another
so that we bought things instead of
relating to other people now you come to
the 21st century in the digital age we
had the possibility and this is what got
so many of us excited in those early
internet days the possibility to really
retrieve all of those cool peer-to-peer
bottom-up values of medievalism and the
commons and the coop all of these things
were starting to emerge but then you
know along comes Wired magazine and
these ideas about how the Internet's
going to save the Nasdaq Stock Exchange
and and allow us to have this
exponential growth like we've never had
before and now we have a whole lot of
digital companies that are not creating
tools or platforms to help people live
their lives they're creating tools and
platforms that really just help
corporations extract value from people
either in terms of their time or their
data or even their consciousness their
choice making so when I say that the
digital landscape has become anti-human
really what I mean is that it's
extending and amplifying kind of the
most anti human or dehumanizing biases
of corporate growth based capitalism and
putting them on digital steroids and
it's really hard for people to really
maintain any sense of coherence or
values in such a space yes so I mean
there's actual technological utopianism
right like really truly the the we will
be happier and more free and self
actualized the more Science and
Technology developed but then there's
more of what I would call like kind of a
passive admiration or maybe an
unquestioning adoption of some of these
technologies that's not as like hard and
fast about we need to push technology
and science as much as possible because
it's inherently good but just sort of
like I'm sure that as all of this stuff
develops it's good to use in a sort of
uncritical way and that's where I see a
lot of the less healthy sort of like a
option of Technology and social media
use coming from this kind of the default
position is I'll use it unless I can
very clearly think of why not to rather
than what Cal Newport for example
advocates which is let's evaluate each
of these tools and technologies one by
one to see what it actually does for us
right I mean I come from the early cyber
culture which was informed by really
kind of the psychedelic West Coast
counterculture and I remember the first
time Timothy Leary that big LSD guru the
first time he used the Internet he said
oh my gosh this is acid you know that
it's as powerful as an LSD trip and the
way it changes the way someone thinks
about the world and the way everything's
connected and the access to information
and people that it gives you but if the
Internet is as powerful as a psychedelic
then it's really important what mindset
and what setting you do that drug in you
know if if you have this set and setting
of I want to do something that's gonna
help people connect in meaningful ways
and help you know the planet and other
species and everybody live more
healthily and make a more egalitarian
economy and an increased social justice
you're gonna get very different effects
than if you're really just a 19 year old
kid who invents something on the net and
then listens to whatever the venture
capitalist tells him to do you know so
we end up you know with technologies
that are as powerful as drugs but we
don't recognize that they're that
powerful you know when you're on the
internet you are on the internet or on
Facebook or on Twitter the same way that
you could be on marijuana or on LSD or
on cocaine and if you really want to
know
you know what a drug is like it's funny
Timothy Leary said this too before you
take any drug look into the eyes of
someone who's on that drug decide if
that's somewhere that you want to be but
none of us are thinking about the way
that we bring these devices and
platforms and apps into our into our
worlds almost almost
soon-to-be into our body
you know I feel like people worry more
about how a program is going to affect
the operating system of their computer
when they install it than how it's going
to affect the operating system of their
lives when they start using it what sort
of advice or guidelines or
infrastructure do you suggest people at
the individual level sort of employ for
having a sort of healthy diet of
technology in their lives well I don't
know that they need any technology in
their diet you know what I mean on a
certain level
it's what's a healthy diet of work
what's a healthy diet of media what's a
healthy diet of online interaction but
almost anything almost anything that you
do through digital technology is a
substitute for something that you could
be doing in real life and I think that
what many of us are learning is that
we're trying to live our lives at scale
you know at the same scale as a
corporation or or a you know a
Kardashian or something it's not a
person a Kardashian maybe there's a
person in there somewhere but it's a
lifestyle that's mediated existence and
we and getting engaged with people in
real life we end up losing the ability
to make eye contact and establish
rapport and breathe with other people so
I don't I don't really think that
there's any you know particularly
healthy or unhealthy amount or quota or
quotient of Technology as long as you
have the sort of the real life
experience and and sustenance for you to
be able to engage in those online
experiences in a healthy way you know
for the most part the people who are
making the platforms that we engage with
each other online they don't have our
best interests at heart but we all know
now they go to classes at Stanford in
kept ology which is you know how to
hypnotize people using digital
technology you know there we take the
the addiction algorithms from Las Vegas
slot machines and
in our social media feeds to get us to
keep checking them so you know in some
sense I feel like almost any use of
digital technology is a compromise and
you have to be aware that okay I'm now
going to compromise the integrity of
this interaction like the one I'm having
with you we're gonna compromise that
interaction in order to reach more
people but if we're very aware of the
ways in which it's compromised that I'm
not making real eye contact with you
that we can't establish rapport with one
another
then we're gonna have to be extra
compassionate and extra conscious that
this that none of the painstakingly
evolved social mechanisms that we have
for establishing rapport with one
another are able to to activate when
we're using this medium yeah in other
words it you and I would arguably have a
better conversation in person but for
the purposes of filming this segment for
my program and we're in different
locations we've sort of made the
compromise that we're going to do it
over Skype over this videoconferencing
technology that has that there are
that's a compromise that we're making
for what I guess we've both calculated
if we've thought about it this deeply is
is a sort of greater good which is we're
gonna get this interview out to people
right and as power users you know I
realized what a power user is is not
someone who understands necessarily how
to reprogram Skype you know or how to
know how is our image happening a power
user is someone who understands those
kind of dehumanizing compromises and
knows how to compensate for it can
accept it you know and that's you know
I'm sure for you when you pick guests or
when I pick podcasts to be on I try to
get a sense of is this someone who
understands that or is this someone
who's a I'm gonna go down some pretty
dark places with because they don't
they're not going to be forgiving enough
of this medium and how it works so along
those lines I mean not to be overly
dystopian but also not not to sugarcoat
it what do you see as the extrapolated
out five years ten years whatever what
do you see as the the real practical
dangers to our war
becoming more technology centric I mean
the main problem with any of these
technologies is that you know the kid
who invents the tech invents it for one
reason but then once they take the money
from the venture capitalists I mean and
these are kids these are college
freshmen who drop out of school you know
with their new app or platform and then
they listen to these venture capitalists
then they have two objectives one is to
do the app or whatever it was that they
they thought they were gonna make and
now the second one is to figure out a
way for that app to also make many
billions of dollars that's really hard
you know Twitter was considered a
failure when it was making two billion
dollars a year which I think that's
about as much money as you could expect
from a hundred and forty character
messaging app but you're not allowed to
stop at two billion you have to keep
growing your company so now Twitter has
to pivot from a messaging company into
an advertising company into a streaming
media company into something else you
know getting more and more becoming more
and more extractive all along the way so
when I look at that trajectory what I
see are a whole lot of CEOs and and
billionaires looking to figure out how
can I earn enough money to insulate
myself from the world that I'm creating
by building these kinds of platforms
there when I I met with these
billionaires kind of by mistake I
thought I was doing a talk and the main
advice they wanted from me was
strategies on their fallout shelters
their doomsday bunkers for the event you
know I've read about that actually they
a couple interested I recommend the
audience google that and read about it
because it's fascinating yeah and I'd
read about its in team human also me
sort of the answer to that but you know
when I look at when I look at that I I
get concerned that we're going to begin
the war with the increasing economic
independent and social unrest and
climate change because you know right
now and I mean luckily it's a it's a
progressive audience I'm speaking to
here but you know even Adam Smith talked
about there being three main factors of
production
and labor and capital right the land
that we use the place where we're
running our company the labor the people
that are working to make this happen
like all those little uber drivers and
then the capital and all three have sort
of an equal place in production but
right now in the digital realm capital
is the only one that has a voice Capital
is the only one that scales infinitely
you and me people and land don't scale
infinitely and when capital is the only
one that has a voice well your labor
gets disenfranchised and your land gets
destroyed so we're dealing with climate
change and we're dealing with economic
inequality so unless we were really to
shift those things gifts you know not
necessarily permanently worse but worse
to a point that people say oh wait a
minute this is not a problem of digital
technology this is a problem of
economics this is a problem of growth
based corporate capitalism that just
happens to be amplified and accelerated
by digital technology so you know the
beauty of it you know my optimistic take
is that digital tech by kind of putting
capitalism on steroids is it it created
something that's almost like the movie
Keanu Scott see you know where
everything happens in fast time and it
because it's happening so quickly this
time we can sort of see it I feel like
most people are more aware of the
extractive nature of the operating
system of this economic operating system
and looking for alternatives so I think
we're gonna start to see the emergence
of cooperatives you know a worker owned
businesses we're gonna see people
treating resources like Commons the same
way we did you know back in the Middle
Ages when we understood this is a
precious resource and rather than
creating a market for it we're going to
guard it as a Commons and and enforce
its use and share it so I'm actually
optimistic that things are happening
clearly enough and quickly enough that
people are going to react from a much
more human centered sustainable outlook
I hope you're right and I do agree that
the speed with which it's happening
does seem to paint a clearer picture of
the fact that that that it is indeed
happening make sure to check out the
book team human we've been speaking with
the book's author Douglas rushkoff
Douglas really a pleasure having you on
today it's good to be on with you thanks
for what you do